we've got these two limits out the way
let's have a look at these next to these
final parts okay and will test how your
logic is going because suddenly they
enter calculus crucible limits right and
then they start talking about
derivatives for a fixed value of alpha
let f of theta equal now what is that
what is f of theta what is significance
to the question it's just the
denominator it's just the donor by the
way please note that can you and this is
your piece of Everest take it out can
you draw a bigger net and say that's the
denominator because a lot of people I
think sort but they didn't understand
that the the implications ones you have
for the next part of the question show
that F dash theta equals zero show
there's a stationary point where and
then give you that okay so are you ready
what would you like me to do to start
off pop3 what they do let's just take f
of theta now let's just differentiate
the thing I'm looking for a stationary
point right and I currently have no
expression for F dash I haven't done any
calculus so far apart from this part of
rivets stuff okay so let's just take
this function and let's differentiate
you know F of theta by definition is
this but no please look for me you guys
are extension one suits you know a whole
bunch of identities in your head and you
know sometimes it's smarter to
manipulate something before you just
watch it to your calculus because this
is a product right can we think of an
easier way to deal with this that you
use the press room yeah this is half of
double egg all right you didn't have to
do this you can do this my product or
just fine but I'm going to write it as
half beside to theta because that is
like that's twice as easy to
differentiate right I don't have to
worry about two functions and we combine
them blah blah blah and then what have I
got minus cos squared theta 10 alpha no
I'm just gonna remind myself because
this is an error made by HSC students
very frequently
that's I'm differentiating with respect
to the theater which I'd better do
because if you have a look at the
question they even tell you that alpha
is fixed right alpha is fixed so it
can't change so it does make it anything
about how that functions changing with
respect to alpha because I was locating
okay so therefore to remind myself of
that one of them right over here is that
beer that alpha is some double that
means 10 alpha is also some normal not a
variable right it's just something that
belongs in that setting ok I'm ready for
gender so f dash or Die video right ok
so the two and a half meters cancel now
I noticed this is cos theta all squared
right so first thing I want to do is I'm
going to put that constants just
deposited at the flood does it affect my
derivative and then if you have
something squared you bring the power
down reduce the power by one and last
step of chain rule there's the inside
derivative looking good now this is even
needed that before because you've got
cause to be be here you've got two
negatives that cancel tan alpha is just
a constant and then you've got oh yeah
that guy good that's nice ok so i have a
derivative right what was that crash
show again we're using this
the second look carefully look at the
question your tried to find try to fight
a stationary point right bless you okay
so if a stationary point is defined when
f dash is equal to 0 right sometimes say
for that value but that to be equal to 0
I just need the right head side to be
equal to 0 right so for that I need cars
to the docks yeah okay there are pause
have a look at the result you are trying
to prove what would you like me to do to
this line i'm going to divide everything
by close to theta does that make sense
suppose I should do this okay i can do
by through that's all fine that gives me
the one that is supposed to come up in
my result it's going to give me the tan
alpha tan 2 theta that I also want and
this is still 0 so I'm pretty much there
I'll time yep we can say that the reason
why we could / cos chiquita is that
because this even if you most mind if I
buy one on cost to be done
Nina the costume year ended that
denominator doesn't play any
significance in terms of whether its
variant would you write that I'll
probably say this is this faster when
you learn the fastest way to knock out a
factor of cause to Dina and then you use
the results yeah they're both wise in
both what ya never fight okay yeah
Sheamus yeah that's okay are you happy
I've got the result ripe fruit that was
part 3 right pad 3 ok have a look at
platform they actually give you this
clue right using Part A Part 2 or
otherwise there you did parte about 15
minutes ago okay so I want you to look
at that and say well how is this ready
to party oh ok so i have a day and i
have a beam surface yeah it would be
advantageous to swap things we know it
wouldn't nevermind ask you look like I
have an A to B her daily if I know that
this is the case for some a and some be
right i'm going to say since 10 alpha 10
2 theta equals negative 1 they're my a
be I know that the difference between a
and B alpha take away 2 theta equals PI
on to that's the difference right now
have a look they actually tell you what
they want you to prove they want see I
write a 1 theta yeah Oh
yes yes that's okay right what should i
do what should I do ok so I'm going to
say let's let's I undo any of those
things in any different water I'm going
to move this guy overheating right and
then i'm going to divide through by
negative 2 ok that'll get me the science
I want so it looks like I'm gonna have a
phone two at the front and ar- yeah look
at that yeah what have I done office so
these guys are in the wrong order yeah
so you guys on their own up now just
pause for a minute because this happens
right did we use the result incorrect
because look at look at this phone right
see this guy you should lose this game
10 10 a 10 B does it matter which one's
envy yeah now interestingly from looking
at this it doesn't look like it matters
because it's just a product yeah it's
just the product but but we know things
about a and B from go back go back from
Part A Part two right remember when I
asked you about a and beans right so and
we actually do matter not from this
result but from that inequality we were
given earlier does that make sense does
that make sense okay all right sure how
should i rewrite this them actually
rewrite this where do I need to go back
to okay very good so you can see here
the actual order and that should make
sense by the way write a minus B a B
minus a that otter does actually manage
so this should really be 2 theta minus
alpha so make sense so what should this
line BTW what should this I beg what am
I gonna get here I'm just going to add
out but both sides so that should really
be 2 theta is PI on two plus alpha does
that make sense and then here I'm just
going to divide through by two not
negative 2 which gives me the sign that
I wanted
on g+ 5.4 okay now of course I could
have told you from the beginning you
need to do this order right but guess
what students any agency did wrong this
and what have you been fixed it when
they go to this way what do you think
they did people but you look up to this
point I'm like oh it's good to be a plus
I can fix that look at my look at my
magic marker ok and guess what happened
to their mark and they clearly lost it
so what we had to do was going back to
say ok something's gone wrong don't just
pretend it's ok something went wrong
from initial some does that make sense